- [Teacher] What's another strategy?
- Uh, area model.
- [Teacher] Area model, okay
who wants to do an area model?
- [Narrator] Because the
Lab school staff gets
regular opportunities to
participate in learning walks,
both as participants and also as hosts,
it really strengthens the
culture of the school,
helps build the shard vision
and allows a spirit of
continuous learning.
- The Lab school is located
on a university campus,
in the College of Education
and we have a dual mission to serve
the children at the school,
which is currently kindergarten
through grade eight
as well as pre-service teachers.
- Learning Walks is a
big part of our mission.
It gives people who are
teaching in our school
as well as people who are
learning how to be teachers
the opportunity to watch
other people teach,
which you don't generally get casue
you're in your classroom
teaching all the time.
- [Margaret] A Learning Walk is just
a structured observation through a school.
It's used for continuous
growth and improvement.
It is important that all
teachers get to experience
what it's like to observe in
other teacher's classrooms
and learn from others as
well as to have teachers
come in and visit them
and learn from them.
- I really like Learning Walks,
especially as a fairly new
teacher to this building.
It's really helped me gain perspective
on what my students have experienced.
It facilitates this, we're
all in this together,
what can we learn from each other?
Some of the times the best
things that are going on
are happening in your own building
and you might miss them
because you're doing your own thing too.
- He can run at a rate
of 11 feet per second.
- The Learning Walks follow
a pretty specific protocol.
It starts with an overview of the process
and sets some parameters
for participation.
Thanks everyone for joining
our Learning Walk team today.
A focus is identified
for the Learning Walks
and it can be a really broad focus,
like teaching and learning
or a pretty specific focus,
like classroom management.
Today's Learning Walk focus
is going to be on Math.
We're going to be looking at
the power of mistakes and struggle,
rich mathematical tasks and
assessment for a growth mindset.
Learning Walk participant's role is to
observe what's happening and know that
they're going to get
an opportunity to talk
about those things later
but to avoid making
judgements and to reframe
any kind of thinking along
those lines into questions.
- Did you understand Miles' answer?
- Yes.
- How would you know
that you made a mistake?
- [Margaret] Participants
are encouraged to take notes
and jot down what they
observe, what they see,
what they hear and also
what their questions are,
things they wonder about.
It gives us a snapshot of
other teacher's teaching.
- How many do I have across here?
- 14.
- And it reminds us of, oh
they did an exit ticket,
I really keep forgetting to do those,
I need to pull those back in.
You know, we catch those little things
because we're always watching
and trying to get new ideas.
The Learning Walk for teachers,
I think is really beneficial.
- I do carry a timer
and I rely on that timer
to keep the Learning Walk moving.
After going through
all of the observations
is a time for reflection
and we generally start
the reflection process
by having a few broad
reflection questions.
Take a minute and look over
the reflection questions.
Reflection is probably the most valuable
part of the Learning Walk.
One of my favorite
reflection questions is,
does anyone want to start
and share any questions,
wonderings, surprises that you noticed?
- Kindergartners, when they
were done with the task,
they partner up with the next person done
and I added that to my ideas that I might
apply in my classroom, I
thought that was really neat.
- Anything that you would
recommend to be changed?
- I would always like to see,
like two minutes longer in each class.
- The amount of time is always hard
but the benefit of going
to six different classrooms
in a short amount of time is that you get
a glimpse of many classrooms instead of
an extended observation of one
and now you know where
you might want to go back
and do some more observing
in that specific classroom.
- This is the first Learning
Walk that I've been on.
It was clear after
being on this today that
it's a powerful tool
because I could see what
my colleagues were doing
in grades behind me
and then grades all the
way up to middle school.
So I can see where I fit in that picture.
- What would the clock look like up here?
And then when we get here, it would be...
- You know, I never get to
step outside and go next door
and see what my colleagues are doing.
I'm always here so,
I think that's really powerful.
- These are fifth graders, right?
- It's amazing how when
teachers go into classrooms,
even if they're different levels
and different content
areas from what they teach,
what they can learn from each other
and I've never had a Learning Walk where
people didn't walk away with some ideas
about something new that they saw,
something they want to try,
something that they were interested in.